[Musique]
alors il existe plusieurs types de
masques d'abord les masques dits ffp2
les plus protecteurs celui ci n'est plus
stérile c'est un masque de démonstration
qui sont évidemment réservé aux services
hospitaliers ou au médecin
deuxième type de masque là aussi pour
l'instant réservé aux médecins aux
soignants mais qui peut-être le sont
ouverts au public dans quelques temps ne
sait pas encore ce sont les masques
chirurgicaux les masques plat et enfin
troisième type de masque les masques
alternatifs les masques en textile que
vous pouvez confectionner vous-même
alors pour la mise en place des masques
chirurgicaux l'important est de repérer
le sens du mas vous avez une barre qui
vous indique que vous êtes dans le sens
de la hauteur et vous avez également une
surface externe et interne
en général il ya un petit symbole qui
peut ici être apparent externe mais
d'autres fois et bien ça peut être la
surface colorée par exemple qui à
l'extérieur et la surface décolorés à
l'intérieur vous avez également le
système de fixation qui est à
l'intérieur et non pas à l'extérieur du
masque par exemple sur ce type de modèle
et pour l'enfiler bien sûr vous devez
vous être lavé les mains avant de
prendre le masque et de le fixer et vous
devez ensuite le placer ainsi sur le nez
avec la barre qui va permettre d'épouser
la forme du nez puis passer les lanières
derrière les oreilles et enfin rabattre
pour bien couvrir le cou et éviter en
principe toute la surface y compris
latéralement et bien couverte par le
masque ce qui va vous permettre de le
garder pendant environ quatre heures
maximum et ensuite eh bien lorsque vous
l'enlevez bien sûr vous ne touchez pas
cette surface qui est potentiellement
contaminés vous prenez les lanières de
chaque côté et vous allez jeter le
masque car ce sont des masques à usage
unique
alors là une fois que vous aurez enlever
le masque et jeté à la poubelle bien sûr
vous vous allez à nouveau vous laver les
mains pour l'instant évidemment ces
masques ne sont pas disponibles pour le
public lorsqu'ils sont en pharmacie ils
sont réservées réquisitionnés pour les
soignants vous ne pourrez pas vous en
procurer mais peut-être qu'à terme vous
le pourrez enfin pour le troisième type
de masque les mains
cette fois ci en textile et bien c'est
un peu délicat parce que effectivement
les pouvoirs publics nous rappelle que
c'est mieux que rien mais en réalité il
faut quand même savoir et la société
française de d'hygiène hospitalière l'a
rappelé récemment dans un communiqué
conjoint avec la société des sciences de
stérilisation et bien il n'y a aucune
preuve scientifique de leur efficacité
alors néanmoins les recommandations de
bon sens sont que si vous utilisez ce
type de de protection en textile vous
devez de la même façon considéré qu'une
fois que vous les avez porté à
l'extérieur est bien à son ses masques
sont contaminés donc vous allez devoir
les nettoyer mais là aussi évidemment il
n'y a aucune recommandation des sociétés
savantes pour le type de lavage à faire
car on n'a aucune idée ne du maintien de
protection c'est d'ailleurs une règle
qui est valable pour tous les types de
masques en principe ils ne sont pas
réutilisables les autres types de
masques donc il n'est pas la peine
d'essayer des recettes de cuisine dans
les mettant au four au micro ondes ou
utiliser un produit des infections
quelconque vous risquer de perturber la
protection d'altérer les capacités de
filtration de ces masses et de vous
croire protégés alors que vous ne l'êtes
pas donc rester prudents respectez bien
sûr les mesures barrières que vous ayez
un masque ou que vous n'en ayez pas